[Music]
for years Sony has tried to launch a
spider-verse to call its own some have
been good
some have been bad some have been phenom
and some never even started swinging now
they're back with an all-new strategy
saying it and doing all the spider stuff
at once spider-man into the spider verse
strapped it with this fresh take on your
favorite neighborhood superhero that's
probably one of the best movies of 2018
but it's got a lot of spiders in it I
know we need to work on art man maybe
I'll just write the clock on this one by
pushing random buttons in my booth
what's this one do whoa I don't think
I'm in my recording booth anymore who
are you I'm a big geek girl the voice of
honest trailers from an alternate
dimension just sunny upbeat and
emotionally healthier and and what
that's all the explanation the movie
game want to team up for this one
heck yeah suit up for a fresh new take
on the spider-man franchise that
combines jaw-dropping camerawork and
fever dream visuals with a multicultural
hip-hop fueled New York that proves Sony
product placement is the one constant in
the multiverse to create a mold breaking
superhero story with the men of Deadpool
and Lego Batman Senator Camco what's
Comic Con so hard it's Superman and the
visual style of pix actually this movie
doesn't look anything like the animation
we've gotten used to does every animated
character in your reality do the
eyebrows thing - yep
this booth is getting kind of crowded
who are you three I'm the epic dungeon
master a far traveler from a distant
realm who earns his key being critical
about movies yes yo la voz época la
mujer telenovela your aggressor Bastion
I lost honest trailers
good eye I'm Australian voice guy I'm
Australian huh how does that work mixin
switch shall we continue this quest
let's do this bark you're Peters because
there's an all-new spider-man on the
block Miles Morales he's a relatable
sweet nerdy high school kid that was
bitten by a radioactive spider he deaths
through evil more than a muy difícil
deal he's sewer more for Gwen Stacy wait
how is he all new this spot a man likes
completely different but you won't want
to walk a mile in his loose-fitting
shoes because this spider guy doesn't
just have one coming-of-age problem he's
got all of them from dealing with his
demanding dad finding his artistic voice
to fitting in and a new school a month
in the end the one a more approachable
they all throw demons Jones living away
from home for the first time and puberty
it's a puberty thing I don't know why I
said that
crikey just very much for you buddy
please stop sticking but miles isn't
alone on his spider quest because plenty
of spider folk are joining his party
from the hot bod version to the dad bod
version Nicolas Cage
I see no Cabana babe and peaceful
sometimes I let matches burn down to my
fingertips just to feel something
anything
John Mulaney playing himself I just
washed my hands that's why they're wet
and one that's so anime I'm amazed she's
not licensed by Funimation
together they'll battle all-new takes on
classic spider bad guys like the chaotic
neutral and completely terrifying
Prowler and the sexy cat lady version of
Doc Ock all there by the kingpin
a tragic villain mourning the loss of
his wife his son and his neck
hey don't take my punchlines in my own
booth sorry might sorry this is a mess
out of the movie keep all this
manageable so take the leap with a movie
that sounded like a terrible idea when
you first heard about it but ended up
being so good we can't wait for more
miles or Gwen Stacy calm down Down Under
get it on Australian Oh Eunice Agata
Delambre ranked entrando second su
propio kalanick o los dos carry on dos
SL a Peter Parker well pero no momento
climactic Oh
uno same wedding you know next Monsieur
or Chronicle except for that one
well guys it's been fun but it's time to
wrap up how do you want to do this
starring well I would watch 500 miles
Peter Pienaar plucked a pack of Peter
Parker's depression sweats depression
sweats there is sad as things can get
quadric lose Plus baby 2099 squidy woman
jon hamm my hero academia Cage Against
the Machine and hey and purposive ah
ally bug hero 6 you know you guys could
always stay we could be an epic voice
family sorry Mike kangaroos do box of a
musketeer more Luca podemos estar juntos
you think ok regressor let me pour your
coffee until we meet again my friend is
it Tuesday yet plus if we stay here our
atoms will explode so later nerd
bye Felicia oh man I have to come back
soon because I'm not watching the jared
leto Morbius movie by myself
thanks to my epic voice worst friend
Felicia Day check out her new sci-fi
comedy podcast voyage to the stars
wherever you get your podcasts and to
Matt Mercer to learn more about critical
role in the Kickstarter for their
animated series visit crit role calm is
the first episode of our new series
fandom uncovered about Twilight fans yes
do we have a healthy history with
Twilight no but should you check out the
show anyway yes yes and yes so click the
box to watch now Beetlejuice Beetlejuice
Beetlejuice winter is coming